[Music]
we're both dead inside why the hell did
you come after me I didn't come up you
[ __ ] I came for her
I guess always knew this day was gonna
come
[Music]
you just ate today guy comes up offers
me a fight big dude wanna fight to fight
yeah I'll fight the big fight
you must want to hurt me bad I'm not
gonna hurt you I'm gonna take your life
even taste it and I can kill you with
this piece of Apple okay all right why'd
you do that distraction you hit me you
hurt me you hit me long cheap shot me
I'll get you out of it
you know a lot of people come to Vegas
to lose I did
you see this
after I cover my tracks I had one minute
to make it to the fire response ship
before the team did
before you know it I'm right where I
want to be just in time to catch my ride
and there isn't one of us that doesn't
want to be someplace else but this is
what we do who we are
live for nothing but die for something
you're coming out
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]